لقد مات كل هؤلاء
الأشخاص وهناك الكثير من
هذا
الجدار ، كل الأشخاص الذين فقدوا
حياتهم مبكرًا بسبب الإدمان ،
نعم هذا من أكرون ،
لن نتعامل مع طريقنا للخروج من هذا
الوباء بالطريقة الوحيدة  القضاء عليه
يكون من خلال التعليم
والوقاية ومنع الأطفال من استخدامه
لأننا رأينا أشخاصًا يمرون ببرامج
10 و 12 مرة مختلفة ويذهبون إلى
العلاج
ولا يحصلون عليه مطلقًا وينتهي بهم الأمر بالموت ،
لذا فالرجل هنا كان منزلاً
المراقبة في مركز علاج القدر الجديد
ووجدوه ميتًا تمامًا مثل
هذا
يقف ميتًا رجلًا هنا وصديقته
وُجدا في شقتهما
أنهما قد احتضناهما للتو وماتوا لمدة
ثلاثة أيام وهم
يمسكون ببعضهم البعض
[  موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
نحن في سكن استرداد إيما
منزل كان في عائلتي لأكثر من
50 عامًا و 53 عامًا أعتقد
أنك تعلم أنني قرأت بعض المقالات
الافتتاحية مؤخرًا حيث
يقول الناس إن الأمر أسوأ  خلفنا
وهذا بعيد كل البعد عن الحقيقة ،
فإن الإحصائيات مثل أنها
مخيبة للآمال الآن ، لقد أصدروا للتو
تقرير مقاطعة حيث كانوا في
طريقهم لتجاوز وفيات العام الماضي
قرارًا مهمًا تقريبًا أيضًا
أنا أجنبية أيضًا بعد مرور عشرة أشهر على هذه الرحلة.
يعني حقًا أنني على قيد الحياة ، هذا ضخم ،
آه آخر مشروبي وتعاطي المخدرات ،
قفزت من نافذة شقتي المكونة من أربعة طوابق
على الرصيف ، وأه
لا ينبغي أن أكون على قيد الحياة هنا اليوم ،
فلا يجب أن أكون قادرًا على المشي
أه مجرد شيء آخر بهذا كله
شيء التعافي ، فقط افعل الشيء الصحيح التالي
وأنت تعلم أن الأمور تميل إلى العمل.
أو اثنين
كنت إما أن أصاب بالشلل أو كنت
سأموت فقط استعد
صحتي وأكون أكثر امتنانًا لأنني ما زلت على قيد الحياة
في المرة الأخيرة التي كنت فيها هنا كنت
أدخن بونغ هنا بينما كنت
أطهو نوعًا من المخدرات في  المطبخ
فقط غرام  أعطتني أتفول برنارد
فرصة أخرى
، وهذا أنا كان هذا الطفل على حق بعد
أن
تبنوني ، لقد تم تبنيها في أربعة أيام من عمري ، قابلت
والدتي
لكنها لا تعرف حتى من هو والدي ،
الغموض الكبير لا يفعل ذلك حقًا  أهتم ليس الأمر
مهمًا ،
فأنا لدي عائلة كبيرة على أي حال
، فهذه هي صورتي الكبيرة ، لذا كان عمري
17 عامًا ونصف
هناك وكنت شقراء ، ثم
كنت مكسورة تمامًا ، كما تعلمون ، لقد
تركت الكلية عندما تعرضت للاغتصاب في
ذلك الدرج
كما تعلم  هذا عندما كنت مثل بدأت في
الشرب وكان هذا كما
لو كان الإدمان بداخلي
مستيقظًا
ولكن لا أحب إطعامه باستمرار
أو مثل التغذية كما أعني أنني رعت
بطليتي ، فقد جعل كل ما
تم كسره بداخلي يذهب بعيدًا
آمل أن يكون قادرًا  للتحدث إلى هذا
الشاب
وزرع هذا الرجل البذرة ، هذا
كل ما يدور حولك ، كل ما يتطلبه الأمر هو
أن يتواصل شخص واحد مع
شخص آخر تعرفه يؤمن بشخص
آخر
أنا متأكد من أنني ربما أشرت إليه قبل
ابن عم جون م  أنت تبدو مألوفًا ،
جاك وايت ، عمي ، أنا على حق ، أنا روب
من هو عمك جاك
كاثي فايس ، أمي تبدو مألوفة ،
أعني أن البحث حاسم جدًا ،
أعني أن لدينا علامات
وراثية للإدمان ، والتخلص من
الإدمان
بالتأكيد  تعلمنا السلوك
أيضًا ،
فلدينا الآن ثلاثة أجيال من
الناس
تحت سقف واحد يعرفون الإدمان النشط
ومرة أخرى هذا علم أمراض مت
ذر جدًا ، أعني كيف يمكنك مق
طعة تلك الدورة عندما تكون جدتك عالية في
ناول حبوب منع الحمل يض
ع أبي في هذا وأنت تعرف ال
طفال  كنت على الميثامفيتامين ،
حيث تبدأ في حل هذا الأمر ،
فأنا سأصل إلى هناك يا أخي لأنني
لا أريد أن أكون إحصائية ،
أريد أن أعطي أطفالي
شيئًا لم يكن لدي مثل أنني كنت
أخرج من دور الحضانة  حياتي كلها
لم يستطع والدي إدارة أمواله ،
لقد كانت أمي مخدرة ، أنت تعرف
عماتي وأعمامي ،
لقد أتيت
إلى أوهايو
وكانت عائلتي بأكملها مدمنة على المخدرات
كانت عاصفة رائعة
كرة القدم  ctors نحن الآن فقط نقشر
طبقات الصدمة
خلال معظم التسعينيات وما
بعده تم
تشجيع الأطباء وفي بعض الحالات تم
تحفيزهم على
الإفراط في الوصف لدينا مدن صغيرة
هنا في أوهايو تحيط بنا والتي
تم وصفها
بملايين الحبوب أعني  بما يكفي لتهدئة
بلد صغير ، ثم كان لدينا كارتلات سينالوا
والكارتلات المكسيكية الأخرى
التي لديها مراكز توزيع في جميع أنحاء
حزام الصدأ في الغرب
الأوسط أوهايو ، ومن بينها ،
تم تصميم وبناء هذا النصب التذكاري بالفعل من
قبل الشباب
المقيمين لدينا هنا.  سكان الانتعاش
جزء مما نحن جزء مما نقوم به هو
أننا نقدم
مراسم في حياة هؤلاء الشباب
حفل الموت الذي
بدأ في عام 2013 قمنا بدفن
أول
شاب لنا من المنزل هنا
واه لم يهدأ وهم كذلك
الاستسلام ،
فأنت تعرف واحدًا تلو الآخر ، لذا فهذه
كلها علامات مخصصة
للأرواح الشابة التي أتت إلينا
وطلبت المساعدة
وأه هناك الكثير  قادمًا
[تصفيق]
كان لدينا اثنان من
طاقمنا من الرجال الأساسيين الذين عاشوا في المنزل
عندما غادروا ضد المجلس بعد
48 ساعة ، ماتوا
وانتكسوا وتوقفت قلوبهم عن استعادة
جزء من التحدي إذا بقيت  في
التعافي ، من الواضح أن تحملك
ينخفض بشكل كبير ، لذا عليك ال
ودة وصدقوني أن التأخير في الأرض قد تغ
ر بشكل كبير ، أعني أننا نت
دث عن ما
ة كيميائية يمكن أن توقف قلبك مع ال
تلة الصافية لح
ة ملح يمكن أن تو
فك  قلب
[موسيقى]
ثم
أفعل كثيرًا وأضرب الأرض ،
اعتدت أن أفكر دائمًا
أن السبب وراء رغبتك في قتل
زبائنك
ولكن بعد ذلك عندما كنت أسمع أيضًا عن
أناس يموتون ، قل راي راي  هنا
أريد
ذلك ، نعم ، توفي شخص ما ثلاثة أشخاص للتو
بسبب ذلك ، هذا هو ذلك
الرجل الجيد الذي حصلنا عليه أن هذا الرجل
كان مجنونًا ، لقد فعل كثيرًا ولم يكن
يعرف ما كان يفعله ، أنا مختلف أنت لا تفعل ذلك
لا أعرف من أنا
رجل أنا سارق  يا رولينز لا تعرف من
أنت كلب تشاك ولن
نفعل نفس الشيء
الذي تعرفه يا أخي ، لقد حصلنا عليه يا أخي ، دعنا نذهب نحصل
عليه ،
كلانا انتهينا من ضرب كلانا على
الأرض
نحن فيه  منزل ، لا يوجد أحد من حولنا ،
يخمن
أنه ليس صعبًا مرة واحدة انتقلت إلى
منزل رصين ولم أرغب في أن أكون متيقظًا بعد ، لكنني
اعتقدت أنني فعلت ذلك ،
لكنني كنت أسير إلى الحافلة التي تعرفها
من المنزل الرصين  في
منطقة كبيرة في شارع بني والتقيت بالتاجر الذي أتعامل معه وهو
يمشي إلى محطة الحافلات ، كان الأمر كما لو
كنت تريد عينة
بهذه السهولة التي تعرفها وكنت
متأكدًا مثل ما الذي تضعه على ما
تعرفه وهذا هو  كانت تلك
إحدى انتكاساتي ،
أحد النتائج الثانوية الغريبة بالطبع
للوباء هو
وباء الجريمة المتناسب
وقد قرأت للتو هنا حيث تم إطلاق النار على ثلاثة شبان
في الشارع هنا
في معركة بالأسلحة النارية ، أعني
أننا نتحدث عن
المدينة نحن مائة ومائة وتسعين
ألف
شخص ونحن ندير ز  معارك الأمم المتحدة
أعني أنها مثل شيكاغو
في الثلاثينيات ، صحيح إنها موجة من
الجريمة ، لقد أصابت جولات بالمبنى
المجاور
في جولات تسع مليمترات من
خلال نوافذ الصورة ، لذا
هذا هو الغرب المتوحش الذي تعرفه
من الوباء
[موسيقى]
نعم ، حسنًا ، سنضع هذا
هنا هنا ، يا إلهي ، لقد كنت أحاول
الحصول عليها ،
أنا لست أماً ، لست هنا ، حسنًا ، نحن في
كنيسة إيه بي سي الكنيسة أكرون للكتاب المقدس في شارع بني
وقد جئنا إلى هنا للقيام بجذع أو
علاج ،
إنه المكان الذي يسافر فيه الأطفال
من صندوق السيارة إلى السيارة
بملابسهم ويحصلون على الحلوى لأن
عيد الهالوين قادم وهي
كنيسة للشفاء وهذا ما يفعلونه هو ما يفعلونه
غالبية الجميع هنا في حالة
التعافي  من نوع من الإدمان ،
إنه حي
قاسٍ ، رباني والدي أثناء ممارسة الملاكمة ،
لقد رباني كما لو كنت ابنه
بدلاً من ابنته ،
لذا فهذه هي الطريقة التي أرتدي بها ملابسي ، وكان الكثير من
الناس يسخرون مني بسبب
ذلك وبعد ذلك  في المنزل والدي
يختار زوجة أبي  أشعر أنني أشعر بذلك
لأنها لم تعجبني ولم تعجبها العلاقة التي كانت بيني
وأبي وأراد نوعًا ما أن يرضيها
أي نوع تركني
وحيدًا أعتقد أن هذا هو المكان الذي بدأ فيه كل
شيء  أردت فقط أن أنام مع
شخص ما حتى لو كان ذلك لليلة واحدة
فقط لأنك تعرف خمس دقائق أو
ساعتين من التواجد مع
شخص ما لليلة واحدة جعلني أشعر
وكأنني كنت أحترم نفسي ، فإن الأدوية
ستخدر ذلك ولكن بعد ذلك  المزيد من
الأشخاص الذين أنام معهم
أو كلما زادت الأشياء السيئة التي فعلتها
أو كنت تعرف الأشخاص الذين آذيتهم ، كان
علي استخدام المزيد من المخدرات
لمحاولة تخدير تلك المشاعر
فوق المشاعر التي أشعر بالخدر بالفعل
وكانت مجرد عملية  التي لم تنته أبدًا ،
ثم وصلت في النهاية إلى النقطة
التي
لم ينجح فيها شيء ،
هذا هو المكان الذي لعبت فيه
لعبة البيسبول ، نعم كنت جيدًا في ذلك ، لقد
لعبت في الدوري العالمي عندما
كان عمري 14 عامًا.
كانت لعبة الهروب من البيسبول مهربتي
بسبب طفولتي التي عشتها
كبرت ، استخدمتها
كقوة دافعة عندما كانت لدي لحظات
ما زلت أتيت إلى
هنا ، فهذه هي المنطقة الآمنة الخاصة بي إذا
كنت ستعرف أنني أحب أن أكون حول الأطفال
وأحب أن تعرف مساعدة الأطفال والأشياء
إلى النقطة التي كنت فيها  في النهاية ، لا
أريد أن أقول إنني أستخدمها لأطفالهم ،
لكنني أذهب وأقضي المزيد من الوقت
هناك لأن لديهم أطفالًا لأنه
يسمح لي
بفك ضغط المزيد من الحليب ،
كما تعلم ، لم أكن موجودًا
لأطفالي  فعلت ما بوسعها يا رجل
لا تخجل أه هذا جيد معي
كان والدي مسيئًا عقليًا جسديًا جدًا
لقد فقدت الكثير من الملابس في مثل
استخدام الأيام
والأشياء المنكسرة والدي المسكين في كل مرة
أذهب إليها  العلاج
كان عليه أن يشتري لي ملابس جديدة إلى حد كبير
حصل عليها بشكل جيد
مثل الذهاب إلى المتجر والحصول
على ملابس
نسائية مثل السيدات في المتجر مثل يعرفه
أنهم مثل ، هل تحتاج إلى المزيد من الملابس نعم
أبي وجدته  هذا الحي
بالنسبة لنا كان يعتقد أنه سيكون
مكانًا جيدًا للبدء  عائلة ،
نعم بدون والدها ، لن نكون
هنا لا
ولكن هذا ما يتطلبه الأمر يتطلب دعم الأسرة
مستلزمات الأطفال المزيد من أغراض الأطفال
هذه مخصصة للغلاف ولكن ها نحن
[تصفيق]
نعم نحن على وشك الاستعداد
هناك ،
لذا فإن آن وآندي الخشنة
لديهما منذ أن كنت طفلة صغيرة ،
حصلت أمي على تلك
الأشياء التي يجمعونها الآن ، وأعتقد أن
والدي احتفظ
بها مثل كل هذه السنوات ، ثم
أعطاها لي من أجل
ليزي
نحن  في مقبرة جبل السلام
في منطقة المرتفعات المربعة في أه أكرون
أوهايو ،
نأتي كل صباح بالطبع ليقوم بي
بعمله ،
لكننا أيضًا نزور عددًا من
عصابتنا غير الملائمة
وهذا المكان
مزروع معهم
الآن كان توم في السادسة والثلاثين بالفعل  واحد
من أوائل
المتطوعين والموظفين بالمعهد فقط
روح إبداعية هائلة
حقًا إنه شخص جميل أيضًا ، لقد بدا
وكأنه فايكنغ ، لكن
آه 36
كان
[موسيقى]
المضي قدمًا
لقد مات ابننا 18 يومًا
وتوفي في 12 نوفمبر
وتلقيت المكالمة أ  t 8 36
في الصباح كان سيث
[الموسيقى
] مدمنًا خاصًا
على الكحول كان مشكلة بالنسبة له ولكن
شراب السعال وهذا
ما يسمى dxm العنصر النشط
في شراب السعال وهو
الدراماثورافان وهو واسم الشارع
له  يسمى robo tripping من
robitussin وما
سيفعله هو أنه سيشرب عدة زجاجات
منه وسيؤدي إلى تأثير مهلوس
وهذا ما كان يفعله ،
أعني أنه كان
يتعاطى المخدرات إلى حد كبير لمدة 12 عامًا  كان
لديه بعض
القواعد الصارمة للغاية التي قال إنه
لا يوجد ميث لا هيروين كما تعلم ، قال إن هؤلاء
لا يعبثون مع هؤلاء ، لذلك نعتقد حقًا
أنه يعتقد أنه كان يتعامل مع
هذا الأمر
أنه كان يستخدمه بشكل صحيح
ولم يكن تمامًا
على استعداد للتخلي عنه ، اعتقد أنه
يمكنه التعامل معها ، نعم
سيث أبل ،
كلا
جيدًا ، كان لدينا ليزي
الصغيرة إليزابيث في السادس من نوفمبر
في الساعة 1 55 مساءً ، لذا لم يكن هذا طفلي الأول ،
إنه طفل كوري الأول ،
تم تبني طفلي الأول باختياري
قررت أنا وعائلتي أنه كان الخيار الأفضل
وأنت تعلم أن أبناء عمومتي انتهوا
بتبني أمها ،
لكن المرة الأولى كانت مجرد
فوضى كما تعلم
كنت أحاول أن أفهم الرصانة
ثم أحاول أن أصبح أماً
في نفس الوقت و  يبدو الأمر وكأنه
لم ينجح في الأساس
[موسيقى
] أهم شيء في
رجل التعافي لا تفقد نفسك وأنت تحاول مساعدة
الآخرين على العثور على أنفسهم من الواضح أن
الجميع يريد مساعدة الجميع ،
فالوباء أمر مثير للسخرية
هناك اعتني بنفسك قبل أن تعتني بنفسك
من شخص آخر تعرف أنك لست
جيدًا لأي شخص آخر إذا كنت تصب
من فنجان فارغ ، فلا يمكنك نقل
شيء لا تملكه
تدير منزلًا مع 14 رجلاً وفي كل
مرة كنت أنزل في كل مرة أفعل فيها
في كل مرة أشعر بالألم ،
سأذهب لأجد أحد الرجال في
المنزل وأرى ما يحتاجون إليه
لأنك ترى أنك تشعر بشعور جيد
عندما تساعد شخصًا آخر ،
المشكلة هي أنه لا يمكنك استخدام ذلك
كبديل  إنستيا  د مني يخرج
ويطلق النار على المنشطات
عندما أشعر بأنني كنت ذاهبًا
وأمسك بشخص آخر
وأساعده وهذا هو الشيء نفسه
الذي تعرفه إذا لم أصلح
المشكلة والمشكلة هي أنا ،
فهذا مجرد وضع  ضمادة على ذلك
لأنه عندما تختفي هذه الأشياء تمامًا
مثل الأدوية
التي ستمرض ، فأنت تعلم أنني كنت
أستخدم الرجال كأدوية ،
لذا فقد انتكست في رأسي
لفترة طويلة قبل أن أضع الدواء فيها
بالنسبة لي ،
إنها تنتكس هي أنها عملية
يبدأها أو تبدأ عقليًا ،
ثم تصبح عاطفية للغاية بحلول الوقت
الذي تصل فيه إلى الجزء المادي ، إنها
ببساطة تعيد
فقط سبعة بالمائة من المدمنين إلى
النظافة أو شيئًا ما ،
ويستغرق الأمر  مدمن الهيروين
في المتوسط ينكسون ثماني مرات إذا لم
موتوا إذ
أضفت كل مركز علاج كن
فيه من
أن بدأت رحلتي في ال
فاء ثم الانتكاس ثم ال
ودة إلى الشفاء ثم الانتكاس وم
إلى ذل
.  قضيت ما يقرب من ثلاث سنوات
في البرامج وهذا لا يحسب الوقت
الذي أمضيته في حياة رصينة ،
كما تعلم ، ولكن في كل مرة
أذهب فيها ، تعلم أنها زرعت
بذرة وجعلتني أقوم بإجراء المزيد من الاتصالات ،
لم يكن ذلك كله هباءً
لأنني أجلس
هنا وأنا  أنا على قيد الحياة وأرد الجميل
للمجتمع الذي
اعتدت أن أكون عبئًا عليه
الآن ،
أعني
أن لديهم هذا الاعتقاد الخاطئ بأن
الشوارع تهتم بهم
وأن هؤلاء الأشخاص يدعمونهم
الموجودين في الشارع ولكن إذا حصلوا عليها  بعض
الدعم هنا
كما تعلم ويمكنك تقديمه لهم
ليحبوا طريقة أفضل للعيش
ببطء ، فلن يكون الأمر سريعًا
ولن يكون الأمر كما تعلم ،
ولكن ربما سيعلمون يومًا ما
أنهم ربما لن يكونوا مثل الأسوأ
الشيء في هذا المجال هو
أنك ستشاهد الناس يموتون وستشاهدهم يقتلون
أنفسهم
كما تعلمون أنا أطفالي لدي أربعة أطفال
مع
ثلاثة آباء مختلفين
والد ابنتي الأولى قام بتعليق
أطفالي الثاني والطفلين الأوسطين
لدي دالاس وشركاه  ليتون ، البالغ من العمر خمسة
وأربعة
أعوام ، والدهم مدمن على الكحول
وهو نظيف الآن ، لكن
آخر طفل لدي والده لا يزال في حالة
إدمان نشط
حتى يومنا هذا ، لذا فإن الاحتمالات أن يكون واحدًا من
بين كل أربعة من أطفالي مدمنًا
على الأقل ولكن  إذا كنت أعيش بالطريقة الصحيحة
وأريهم كيف يعيشون
بدلاً من إخبارهم كيف يعيشون ،
فقد قمت بعملي ،
يمكنني فقط أن أكون قدوة ، وإذا
اختاروا الطريقة المعاكسة ، فلا بأس
سأكون هنا من
أجلهم فزت  تم تمكينهم ولكني سأكون هنا من
أجلهم ، فقط
بضعة أخبار ، أي شخص
يتابع
ما يحدث في مقاطعة فرانكلين هذا
الأسبوع 28 حالة وفاة
في 10 أيام مرة أخرى وهي 28 حالة وفاة
لرجل [موسيقى]
مرة أخرى أعتقد أنه من المهم ملاحظة
ذلك  إنه ليس
وباءً أفيونيًا أعني أنه ربما في نهاية المطاف
وباء روح إنه حقيقة
أننا أصبحنا
منفصلين جدًا ومجردين من الروح والمجتمع
للمضي قدمًا الآن الكثير
منكم سوف تعملون جميعًا بقدرات
مختلفة تمامًا
[موسيقى]